hi I'm Christopher hin today we're going
to talk about the shanci series and how
all the techniques in the shanci series
explain other problems that will happen
from sh manucci so when I talk about
Hines 57 I put the whole sh manucci
Series in there so I think you need to
know everything from sh minucci because
I think you could really probably just
study the shanci series and and come
pretty close to understanding the basics
of iido um there's a lot of stuff from
the grabs stuff that you wouldn't
understand and some hoki and stuff that
you have problems with but as far as
just moving and applying technique and
quickly getting things done the shanci
series is excellent so I'm going to talk
about that I don't think we're going to
be able to get the whole series done
today um but I'm going to talk about how
those kind of Peace meal out we'll
probably make two videos out of this I'm
gonna get Josh over here we're going to
go to work
Josh all right so let's talk about how
sh manucci sets up everything else and
all the forms in chucci are necessary
for understanding a complete picture so
uh I it took me a long time to
understand this and so I know I've
talked about this before forgive me if
if if you're sick of hearing me say this
but I think this is such a hard concept
to get that like I kind of keep talking
about it look show manucci is basically
what I'm going to do if I was in a
situation with Josh and I had a weapon
in my hand and I wanted to get past Josh
I'm going to hit him as I go past him
right that's what I'm going to do if I'm
smart because if I don't do that he's
just going to grab me right so if I
don't do something as I go by boom Josh
is going to grab me somehow right so
everyone who loves talk about a Timmy
and iido here's an example of how a
Timmy sets up everything right is I'm
running I'm G to hit him bang that's
what I'm going to do okay now Josh is
probably going to do what he just did
there he's going to bring those hands up
so as I hit him bang that is the show
manucci position right so it doesn't
have to be
like right so you know we see that in
the forums that's a real clean way to
show it and a good way to get beginners
doing stuff but that's not how it's
going to appear if you do live training
and you're having some group of people
try to get another person that person
will hit and move by like that it'll
happen and the shui Position will come
from that bang all right now from the
shanci position I really have two major
major ideas from this right I either am
going to proceed through EDI right so
I'm just going to continue on my way EDI
or I'm G to shoot a suto moari right now
I could do other stuff and the forms
we'll talk about other things but those
are really my two primaries that I'm
going to hit um why would I hit those
well if I'm going this way anyways so
there's something over there I want to
get to then doing the edem me really
makes a ton of sense to to to continue
on that way if something's coming up
behind me someone's coming up behind me
or I need to change directions or
whatever the sulto war is going to make
a ton of sense and I think you know Su
is something that we see in iido that a
lot of people who do sport martial arts
go well that's a stupid movement why do
they practice that well because sport
people only have one person they're ever
working on right so if you're in a
situation where someone's coming behind
you you're going to have to do this kind
of action all the time super super
useful to do that kind of action all
right so those are going to be my two
primary ideas from that so let's talk
first about the soam Mori because we get
more classic iido techniques from the
soore from the Ed we pretty much get Ed
nag um or a failure of EDI which leads
to soami and let me explain what I mean
by that if I'm trying to get behind Josh
and he starts turning turning turning
turning turning we're going to get in
this this speed the speed race right so
we just call that a race not a speed
race but we're gonna get in this race
right if Josh is faster than me he's
gonna get Ed me if I'm faster than Josh
I'm Gonna Get Ed me right so if I'm
shooting EDI and Josh starts turning
with me it's who's faster right now if
I'm faster I'd just push through and I'd
get Ed or Ed nag um but if he's faster
he's going to get behind me so the suto
moari is a trick to keep him from
getting the Ed position the reason is
because I can turn faster in a smaller
space right so look if Josh comes to my
back right now he's got to travel that
far okay in order to me to keep my back
away all I have to do is turn this much
right so I'm turning way less so as Josh
is coming to my back if I turn this way
I get I'll get the suore before he gets
the edia and I made a whole video
talking about this um what to do off of
failed EDI I think it's on the YouTube
videos um talking about that whole
series but the shui appears a lot or
sorry the sorei appears a lot because of
that reason all right now what are our
go-to techniques well our biggest iido
go-to technique is probably the kotay
now that kind of makes sense if I have
the weapon in my hand because as he
comes towards me I control this hand and
I attack him here right so so that makes
kind of a fair amount of sense that way
if he has the weapon it makes a fair
amount of sense so meaning I'm running
the Hell by and he tries to hit me boom
and I come in here this gives me the
disarm with kodish and and we know
that's a super viable technique because
uh I just posted Maya doing a doing it
live so it's totally a possible
technique um it it can totally come off
so there are reasons that could appear
when I get to the sorei position if he's
coming in that kodish happens and I can
use the knife in this way but I think
something that people forget about is I
can also cross strike this way right so
I don't have to keep holding on to this
this this if he doesn't have a weapon in
it I can just let go and hit him this
way so if Josh is trying to come around
to me just going here boom is a really
really good idea now that sets up for
all the katam manucci stuff now I know
I'm not in the katam manucci position as
I come around in essence I'm in the
katam manucci position right so that
gives us all the katam manucci
techniques from here okay what else it
gives me from here if he were to choose
to grab this hand is it gives me juji
nag now if he had the weapon you can see
that I'm here and if he's coming around
too fast I could switch off boom and I
get the juji nag if I have the weapon
and he hasn't grabbed me yet and I come
this way he is going to um grab me there
and I can grab this hand up boom and
juji nag it if I've switched hands when
I hit him which is not a bad idea
because now I'm in a defended position
as I come to get him with this if he
grabs I end up in the juji nag position
so juji nag off of shanci comes up all
the time when we're hitting with the
near side right so what I mean by that
is I could hit with the far side and I
can also hit with the near side so if I
hit with the near side we're going to
get juji because that hand naturally
come to protect him and he's in a
crossed position so juji nag will appear
all the time from that okay now in the
suore and I think I can only do one more
in this video because I've talked so
much but so I'm here in this position
now if Josh doesn't like this position
he's going to whip his arm around it
like that now when he does that my
initial reaction should always be to hit
at the inside right so if I have an
opening here right so there's an opening
and Josh comes around that and now I
have an opening here I should always hit
in that and I should probably always hit
and triangle my hand's always going to
go there for sure I might eat e me but a
lot of times I'm going to make a
triangle in that and this is just to
keep him from getting me right away so
if he whips his hand around my hand
should be going in here now if he
doesn't like my hand in his face here he
could duck under it right and you see
that in wrestling all the time it's
called the duck under now if as he goes
to do that I pressure and turn we get
kiten right so the kiten nag happens
because he came around my suppression
here I hit his face and now he's trying
to come around my uh my face suppression
right so my my hand in the face he's
trying to come around that and that
gives us kitan so two techniques that
might beat to people like well how would
juji nag ever appear well how would
kitan nag ever appear they appear really
really naturally so understanding the
full series of the shanci series is
really important because it gives us
explanations for every problem that will
arise from the show manucci position
whether I'm choosing to go Eed or
whether I'm choosing to go Su the Moi
either way I'll get that so I'm going to
make another video because there's more
a lot more actually talk I might end up
making three videos to talk about with
this because there's a lot to go lot to
go on here but understanding how one
technique leads into the other naturally
is really really important because
that's actually how live martial arts
come together you're going to try
something they're going to try to stop
it whatever they try to stop with you
should have an immediate answer for and
that's what learning systematic martial
arts is all about so I'm Christopher R
Joshua T my McD's behind that camera
right there